I think one of the main things and we
found in the Twitter files was that if
it's not Trump it's something there's
always demon X that
um their warning audiences away from and
they always come up with a word that is
sort of a non-negotiable code for threat
so it's an evaxer right or domestic
violent extremist or insurrectionist or
anything you know something along those
lines Trump in that sense I think has
been an enormous Boon to the
intelligence Services they've been able
to say hey if you if you code AS
somebody who sides with Trump
um you know essentially they've created
um what I like to call like the sort of
one villain theory of the universe which
is if you're on Trump's side that means
you're on Putin's side which means
you're also on Assad side you're on
orban's side you're on the side of
domestic violence extremism